hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
prions prions are a very interesting
type of infectious disease and they are
so interesting because pre-knowledge
are actually proteins when we think of
infectious disease we typically think of
microorganisms things like bacteria or
fungi also viruses these are the things
that we think of as causing disease not
proteins and so when prions were
actually first discovered there was a
lot of disagreement that this was even
possible but multiple experiments did
eventually show that prions are proteins
that can fold in at least two ways and
critically one conformation that is one
of the folding ways one conformation can
catalyze other prion proteins to fold
that way now if you're interested in
learning more about catalysis and more
about proteins and how they can act as
enzymes then see my video titled
introduction to enzymes but basically
catalysis is simply when a protein acts
as an enzyme to enzyme types of proteins
and they do that perform some function
and so in this situation they are
catalyzing another proteins change in
shape so here we have some drawings I
have the normal proteins and orange and
a prion protein in pink now it's
important for you to remember that the
amino acid sequences of all of these
proteins are the same it's simply that
the
protein has a different shape a
different conformation than the normally
folded proteins and what happens is once
one of these prion proteins is present
it can catalyze a change in shape of a
normal protein and this results in
protein aggregates specifically
aggregates of the prion protein so
basically one prion protein catalyzes a
change in shape for the normal Priya for
the normal protein and that results in
lots of prion proteins so lots of the
ones that have this particular shape
instead of the normal shape and then
they begin to aggregate and why is this
a bad thing why does it cause disease
well it turns out that this type of
situation which we refer to as self
propagation the this self propagation of
prion proteins making more prion
proteins and then aggregating it
actually causes several brain diseases
and different mammals here are a few
that affect humans there's mad cow
disease which you've probably heard of
it's typically linked with contaminated
beef products there's also kuru kuru is
a prion disease that is found in certain
remote tribes of Papua New Guinea who
practiced Janurary cannibalism
that is they actually eat the brains of
other dead tribal members and can get
prion protein from those brains and
there's also crew spelled Jakob disease
which is sometimes a genetic disease and
as other times transmitted from person
to person by way of brain
and critically all of these prion
protein diseases are currently incurable
and they're also currently fatal so
these are serious diseases when
contracted luckily they are still fairly
rare but that is it for today learning
about prions thanks for watching biology
professor and I hope you learned a lot